الجمهورية الطين بلة بطلبها
الانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي.
تماما. فليس لدى الجيش الروسي
القدرة على هذا النوع من الهجوم
طوال ايام الاسبوع امام الجهات
المختصة لاستخراج وثائق السفر
المراقبين وكشفت نقاط ضعفه. وهنا
يقول الخبراء ان الحديث عن كاذب
الجيش الروسي خسائر فادحة خلال
هجومه الذي يستمر منذ شهرين حتى
الاستيلاء على كييف العاصمة
ومناطق اوسع في اوكرانيا. وتكبد
العاملين الى اهاليهم في
مولدوفا. عندما سمع دوي القنابل
ان روسيا قد غزت بلادهم.
المخابرات الاوكرانية توقعت بان
والجوازات. ويقول السكان انهم لن
يتوانوا عن استخدامها للعبور الى
المصائب لا تأتي فرادى. فسيطرة
موسكو على جنوب اوكرانيا ستجعل
اوروبا اذا اقدمت روسيا غزو
مولدوفا. هكذا هو الحال في
دون غزو روسيا ديمولدوفا؟ عادت
روسيا توجيه جهودها العسكرية
مع نفاذ طاقة القوات بعد الهجوم
في دومباص. سكان مولدوفا يصطفون
تهاجم القوات الروسية في الايام
القادمة ميناء اوديسا الواقعة
للسيطرة على منطقة دومبس في شرق
اوكرانيا بعد فشل محاولات
مولدوفا. فمع وجود منطقة
انفصالية موالية لروسيا زادت
موسكو اما الاستسلام لغزو روسي
او التعرض للتدمير. هما خياران
لاوكرانيا. ضعف الاقتصاد هو سبب
اخر قد يجعل من غزو روسيا
العاملة يعمل في روسيا ويعتمد
اقتصاد البلاد على تحويلات هؤلاء
لمولدوفا وشيكا. وبينما تستقبل
مولدوفا اللاجئين الاوكران فهي
على بعد اربعين كيلو مترا فقط من
مولدوفا. علاوة على ان هناك قوات
روسية متمركزة بالفعل في منطقة
الراغبة في الانفصال عن مولدوفا
بداية حرب روسيا على بلاده لكن
لم يصد احد لما قال. دولة ضعيفة.
الاستيلاء على دول اخرى.
زينونسكي ظل يردد هذا الخبر منذ
اشارة الى ان الغزو الروسي ما هو
الا بداية وانهم يريدون بعد ذلك
المضطهدين وازالة النازيين من
اوكرانيا. جاء الرد من الرئيس
تعتمد على روسيا في الاقتصاد.
كما ان جزءا كبيرا من قوتها
بالروسية ويعد ذات السبب الذي
يعتبره بوتين من بين عدة اسباب
الان وانتكاسات كبيرة في ساحة
المعركة فاجأت العديد من
احلاهما مر يواجهان مولدوفا
واضعف البلدان المجاورة
جندي روسي بحسب غزو متوقع. خرج
القائم باعمال قائد المنطقة
الانفصالية على قدميها ويتمركز
هناك ما يقدر بنحو الف وخمسمائة
والتي طلبت بالفعل الاعتراف
باستقلال مؤخرا. ما الذي يحول
طريقة للخروج الى حيث توجد ايضا
حقائق عن اضطهاد سكان الناطقين
العسكرية المركزية في روسيا وقال
ان السيطرة على جنوب اوكرانيا هي
الموالية بالغاز الطبيعي وغيرها
من الامدادات مما يبقي الجمهورية
لانشاء رابط جغرافي مع
ترانسليستيريا كانت في خطاب
بجيوب نفوذ في اوروبا الشرقية
تواصل موسكو دعم ترانسليستريا
تبدو مولدوفا اكثر جيران
اوكرانيا ضعفا امام اي هجوم من
مع بدء حرب روسيا ضد في عاصمة
جمهورية مولدوفا ظن الناس هناك
موسكو منذ التسعينات على الاقل.
وفي اطار سعي روسيا الى الاحتفاظ
تقدمت بطلب للانضمام الى عضوية
الاتحاد الاوروبي جنبا الى جنب
او بالقرب من حدودها. فهل تجر
جمهورية مولدوفا نفسها الى حرب
الدولة من قبل روسيا الرافضة وسع
الاتحاد الاوروبي والناتو شرقا
ونحو سبعين الفا من جنود
الاحتياط ويبلغ عدد سكان البلاد
مليونين وستمائة الف نسمة.
مولدوفا هي دولة محايدة لكنها
لتبرير غزو اوكرانيا وهي كذلك
الادعاءات بتحرير السكان الروس
الاوكراني فولودي مرسيلينسكي.
الذي قال ان تعليق مينيكيا كان
واوكرانيا وجيشها جيش صغير يبلغ
متوسط عدد جنوده سبعة الاف جندي
التالية بعد اوكرانيا? تقع
جمهورية مولدوفا بين رومانيا
لا طاقة لها بها? تقول التقارير
الامريكية ان فكرة سعي روسيا
وتعترف سلطات مولدوفا بعدم
سيطرتها عليها. لماذا مولدوفا هي
مع اوكرانيا وجورجيا. لكن هذا
الطلب قد يكون سببا في تدمير
صغيرا يمتد على طول حدود مولدوفا
مع اوكرانيا عدد سكانه حوالي
السوفيتي الى نشوب حرب اهلية
قصيرة في اوائل التسعينيات بين
ولا حتى روسيا تعترف باستقلال
المنطقة لكنها تعمل كدولة منفصلة
كانت مولدوفة الدولة الصغيرة في
اوروبا الشرقية الواقعة بين
السوفيتي عام الف وتسعمائة
واربعين. وادى انهيار الاتحاد
خمسمائة الف نسمة وتقول صحيفة
واشنطن بوست انه لا توجد دولة
ضد الدب الروسي لكن هذه المرة مع
دولة فقيرة لا حول لها ولا قوة.
جمهورية مولدوفا المستقلة حديثا.
والانفصاليين في الذين ارادوا
الحفاظ على العلاقات السوفيتي.
واصبحت ترانسريا اقليما انفصاليا
وعقله يفكر بغزو مولدوفا. خرج
جنرال كبير في الجيش الروسي
ليؤكد الخبر. فهل تغزو روسيا
مولدوفا حقا? ولماذا? وما هي
ترانسليا? في مولدوفا ينتظر
الناس قرار الغزو بحذر شديد وقلق
من مولدوفا لقمة سائغة للروس.
فهل يفعلها الدب الروسي?
هدف روسي جديد للغزو. لم يكمل
بوتين بعد غزو اوكرانيا حتى وضع
اوكرانيا ورومانيا جزءا من
رومانيا قبل ان يضمها الاتحاد
مع اوكرانيا الغني في حربها ضد
روسيا فمن الذي سيجرؤ على ان يقف
متزايد. فمن يقف مع هذه الدولة
الضعيفة اذ لم تستطع دولة ان تقف
عينيه على دولة سوفيتية سابقة
اخرى. جيش موسكو في اوكرانيا